نقل موقع اكسيوس عن مسؤول امريكي ان
مراجعه الخيارات المتعلقه بالاعتراف
بالدوله الفلسطينيه كانت من القضايا التي
طلب وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكن
من الوزاره النظر فيها واضاف الموقع ان
بلينكن طلب ايضا مراجعه شكل دوله فلسطينيه
منزوعه السلاح بناء على نماذج اخرى في
العالم وقال المسؤول الامريكي ان الغرض من
المراجعه هو النظر في خيارات كيف تنفيذ حل
الدولتين بطريقه تضمن امن اسرائيل واكد ان
البيت الابيض على علم بالمراجعات الجاريه
وان بلينكن لم يوقع على اي سياسه جديده
والخارجيه بصدد وضع قائمه كبيره من
الخيارات كما نقل اكسيوس عن متحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي في البيت الابيض قوله
ان السياسه الامريكيه القائمه منذ فتره
طويله هي ان اي اعتراف بالدوله الفلسطينيه
يجب ان ياتي من خلال مفاوضات مباشره بين
طرفين وليس من خلال اعتراف احادي الجانب
في الامم المتحده وان هذه السياسه لم
تتغير وذكر الموقع عن مسؤول امريكي رفيع
ان مسؤولين في اداره بايدن يعتقدون ان
الاعتراف بالدوله الفلسطينيه ينبغي ان
يكون الخطوه الاولى لا الاخيره في
المفاوضات لحل الصراع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني وان الجهود المبذوله لايجاد
دبلوماسيه للخروج من الحرب في غزه فتحت
الباب امام اعاده التفكير في كثير من
السياسات الامريكيه
القديمه